do you meal prep
what is new prepping should you or just
don't bother how do you even start a
meal prepping let me start by saying
that meal prepping is not intimidating
in fact it is very easy and simple meal
prepping is just a fancy way of
basically cooking for yourself ahead of
time and then portioning them out to be
eaten later on that's all it is think of
it like packing your lunches to work or
school I'm sure you have seen all the
fitness people who will meal prep in
order to get in shape and achieve their
goals meal prepping is not just for the
super fit people in fact it is for
everybody because cooking for yourself
means you're fully in control of what
you put into your body and it encourages
you to eat better it is one of the
easiest ways to look after your health
if you're thinking right now
you know what meal prepping is too
time-consuming I don't have time for
that let me tell you this the amount of
time you spend ordering takeaways or
sitting in a restaurant waiting for your
food is way more than spending three to
four hours cooking for yourself in a
week on top of that you're probably
spending way more on food and eating out
also means eating fruits and loaded with
calories fats and preservatives which
can contribute to your weight gain over
time all these can be avoided if you
meal prep meal prepping makes your time
more efficient because you're only
cooking once or twice a week it helps
you to save lots of money to no more
expensive lunches or takeaways it can
also help you to lose weight and keep
you on a healthy eating track with all
your meals
perhaps in advance you have no reason to
stop and grab unhealthy meals plus you
will be able to portion your mousse
better and pack them with whole foods
rather than eating
she's jugs you're also reducing food
waste in the kitchen
no more forgotten vegetables sitting in
your fridge for weeks so how do you get
started let's talk about the five simple
steps to get you meal popping let's
start with the first step take baby
steps you don't have to prep all your
meals start with one single meal for
instance you can choose to prep your
lunch to take it up with you I suggest
starting with single recipe meals
instead of making meals that require two
to three recipes which can be very
complicated make a one-pot dish that
contains protein cups and vegetables and
start with recipes that you already know
this will give you more confidence in
what you're cooking that's how I got
started I used to make baked fish with
vegetables and eventually I started to
experiment with different recipes you
can check out all my recipe videos on my
channel I believe in keeping things
simple because I know that everybody can
cook remember take baby steps don't try
to do too much and overwhelm yourself so
start with one meal and eventually add
another meal the next step is to know
your ingredients and cooking methods
when it comes to meal prepping and
wanting your nails to keep well for at
least up to four days choose ingredients
that will not produce much liquid when
cooked and can be kept and reheated
without losing much of their texture so
let's start with vegetables some really
great vegetables include carrot broccoli
pumpkin potatoes bell pepper whole
cherry tomatoes cauliflower leafy greens
such as lettuce or spinach rockets and
killed basically foods that will not
produce too much liquid after cooking
and can be kept for days say that
however you can still cook your
vegetables and blend them up to make
vegetable soups which can be frozen and
will last for many weeks and simply
reheat one portion at a time next
protein pretty much all protein are
suitable such as chicken beef fish eggs
tempeh tofu beans or pulses this really
comes down to the cooking method in
order for them to last long fully cook
your protein so make scrambled eggs or a
hard boil eggs and keep them with a
shell on rather than soft boil or
poached same goes to chicken beef or
even fish fully cook them and avoid
consuming medium rare or raw as for bins
and pulses keeping them dry will be the
best option as you can simply toss them
onto salad and take them out with you
now let's move on to greens or greens
are suitable for meal prepping such as
rice quinoa pasta or couscous the key to
making them last long is to store them
separately from any sources and only
reach it at the portion you want to eat
at that time and add a splash of water
to avoid them being too dry and finally
fruits when it comes to fruits at the
best is to choose low-maintenance fruits
basically fruits such as apples pears or
bananas that will keep well and last for
a long time and can be eaten whole
fruits such as grapes and berries can
also be added into your meal prep but be
sure to chill them in the fridge now
that you've identified the ingredients
and cooking methods it is time to write
a plan ask yourself how often do you
want to cook and how many meals in a day
so take a look at your schedule and work
with what's realistic for you for
instance I'll cook twice weekly and
every time I am meal prep it will be
enough for three days for me outside
two hours aside on Sunday to prep my
meals for Monday to wednesday and on
Wednesday I will prep my meals for
Thursday until Saturday and on Sunday
it's just for me to take it easy and
enjoy my meals out in total I'm only
spending four hours every week if you
think about it it is not demanding at
all it is just about making
is your priority another important tip
is to think of your meals in three parts
so your protein cups and or some
vegetables write down what will your
protein cups and vegetables be and
remember keep it simple don't have too
many varieties okay and repeat your
ingredients for those of you who have
been following me you will know that I'm
a pescetarian so for my protein it's
always between fish egg tempeh or tofu
as for my vegetables I like to repeat my
carrots broccoli bell pepper pumpkin and
mama and carry Tomatoes as for cups it
will be rice quinoa crispies or
buckwheat noodles you don't need to have
all ingredients in your meal prep
portion them out and repeat your
ingredients for lunch and dinner as for
snacks simply snack on nuts and seeds or
fruits now that you know what you plan
to cook write a shopping list and let's
go grocery shopping the last thing you
want is to walk into a grocery store
feeling lost and clueless or even
missing out on an important ingredient
later on remember it is about being
efficient when you have a grocery list
it will help you to stay on track and
only buy ingredients you need and avoid
unnecessary temptations or buying junk
personally I like to do my grocery
shopping and cooking on the same day
this allows me to set my time aside and
I know that I will only be working with
fresh ingredients now that you have all
your ingredients this is the final and
most important step you got a new path
always begin with preparing the
ingredients like chopping garlic your
vegetables washing them or marinate your
meat you may want to preheat the oven if
you're using them while you're prepping
your ingredients to save time so start
off with foods that require the longest
cooking time followed by the easier
meals for instance for my meal prep
I'll start by preheating the oven and
chop up all the vegetables the first
dish I'll cook is my dinner which is
baked fish and vegetables because that
will
the longest time to cook while the dish
is cooking in the oven I will go ahead
and prep my lunch tuna salad
there is no cooking required so it is
all just about assembling and putting
the ingredients together now that lunch
is ready I'll move on to prep my snack
but Ngunnawal nut muffins as that will
also take time to cook in the oven so by
the time my muffins are ready to go into
the oven my big fish and vegetables are
done while waiting for my muffins to
cook in the oven and for my fish to cool
down I'll go ahead and prep a breakfast
which is overnight oats and also portion
out my trail mix into three separate
containers for each day all I'm left to
do now is to assemble all my ingredients
into their own containers and this
entire process can be done in less than
two hours the more you meal prep the
quicker and more efficient you will
become added now let's talk about
storing and reheating your meals to keep
them fresh generally all dishes can be
stored in the fridge for up to 4 days if
you plan to store them for more than 4
days then it is best to freeze your
meals when it comes to freezing some
foods work better than others cooked
meals tend to freeze well in airtight
containers foods with high moisture
content such as salad greens tomatoes or
zucchinis are not recommended as they
tend to become mushy when frozen and
thought consumed high liquid ingredients
within 4 days as for reheating your
meals stovetop is the best way to heat
food evenly and preserve texture if you
plan to take your meals out then you can
microwave your meals for one to two
minutes but using plastic containers
it's not recommended I really hope this
video has given you some useful insights
to get you started on your prepping
remember keep it simple and there is no
one correct method as this differs based
on your food preferences cooking ability
schedules and your personal goals the
long term benefits of meal prep
so worth the effort not only it was save
it time where you will start to eat
better and live healthier
so do share with me your tips and tricks
when it comes to the meal prepping in
the comments below I would love to hear
what you do and what your thought to be
useful don't forget to like this video
share this video on to encourage your
friends and family to start meal prep in
your cape be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more healthy
recipes fitness tips and also workout
videos start meal prepping and tag your
new prep pictures add to an assault
official all the best